[Music]
what'd you do this weekend [ __ ] all oh
winded as hell what do you mean this is
like whatever the sinus [ __ ] I got is
just oh really ruining my day really
yeah if I stayed active you know still
lifting left still eating oh yeah I ate
[ __ ] 45 grams of protein this morning
nice that's the one protein shake and
yogurt Greek yogurt oh yes it's it's
packed full of protein gets it done it
really does and cottage cheese but
anyways I don't usually eat breakfast I
usually skip breakfast and then eat
lunch and then have a snack and then eat
dinner yeah but I was like I should see
how it affects my energy and like it's
really hard to get enough protein just
in two meals you care you can't really
do it you have to have three you gotta
eat a [ __ ] ton of meat and like I don't
really want to slam three chicken
breasts that's disgusting steak for you
know lunch and dinner it's disgusting so
I was like I'm gonna try and see what
breakfast is all about I gotta say I'm a
fan you like breakfast this just said
yeah
approves of breakfast it's actually very
good I mean I've always liked breakfast
but it's just like for me to control
like what I eat it's just easier for me
to skip it but Greek yogurt frozen
bloobs and then like a little granola
not too much because you know it's a lot
of sugar in there but yeah um and I we
have like some real you know some tasty
granola it's not like the high protein
[ __ ] it's just like some real yeah
little tasty granola pretty [ __ ] yeah
yeah some [ __ ] granola yeah and then a
little honey and I slam that back and I
gotta say I've been feeling good this
morning yeah high energy not hungry
liquid breakfast is the way I got this
crazy kale protein smoothie no it's just
half a cup of oats it's just healthy as
hell not really protein powder peanut
butter whey protein whey protein yeah
okay peanut butter real peanut butter
can be Jiffy none of that [ __ ] it's
like the organic [ __ ] yeah a little bit
of ice okay A little bit of ice one cup
water kale good good amount of kale and
then just a little bit of milk how many
cows are we talking that one pretty
aggressive okay five six hundo oh and uh
three tablespoons chia seeds Okay yeah
so it's like a health thing too oh yeah
yeah getting your fiber getting some
greens in that [ __ ] and are we slugging
this pre or post workout pre-workout
because studies show that if you have
protein ingested prior to your workout
what's up guys it's Derek welcome back
to more plates no dates I [ __ ] love
that guy Derek yeah yeah yeah me too
I've [ __ ] hilarious story about him
so just for all our exercise fans out
there no I just I saw this video
um that if you ingest protein
pre-workout you can go lift and then
that whole myth about like oh you got to
eat a meal in 30 minutes because you've
already ingested the protein as long as
you eat within like an hour or two of
your lift then you're good I see so it
helps like extend the time post lift ah
interesting yeah so I slam that I'll go
lift and then I'll have um just you know
if we want to get in my macros real
quick okay yeah what are we talking you
know then I'll uh you know for breakfast
breakfast pretty simple you know just
nine tablespoons egg whites uh just
throw some spinach together and then
I'll um I'll do about you know 150 200
grams of Japanese sweet potato just do
breakfast oh yeah okay and what is that
giving you carbs or yeah you know just
try a carb low okay yeah just early on
in the day okay try to get it done just
to gain weight you know my my macros for
carbs is pretty high is it yeah I don't
know I don't really know [ __ ] about
macros it's like 300 grams worth you
know really it's just because I'm on an
excessive you know or not excessive but
you know a little bit of an aggressive
plan okay got it you know then I'll then
after that I'll have like a nice little
you know sort of healthy uh beef and
broccoli situation then you know they
don't do the second lunch second lunch
oh yeah really oh yeah what are you
slamming for that just a little you know
a little chicken and uh some veggies
okay yeah a little bit of rice and are
you cooking all this oh yeah I've got a
system dude nice I can get these meals
done in [ __ ] 15 minutes yeah that's
the best fresh it's the best when you
have that one thing you're like okay
this works I'll make this every every
[ __ ] day got my system now yeah and
then you can you know mix up the veggies
and whatever you know just to make it
spicy you know now let's do like a
little pesto pasta at night yeah okay
yeah pastel pasta you know and then for
dessert we'll play in Greek yogurt a
little scoop of ice cream because you
know I'm feeling feeling sexy you mix
Greek yogurt and ice cream and then
protein scoop damn dude so how many
calories are you trying to hit a day so
I'm not doing the full plan yet I'm just
like scaling up to it but it's the cat
calories Wise It's not that many it's
like 27 oh okay so not big portions then
right no no no no I'm just like I try to
be really efficient so it's like not a
ton of calories but like a fishing on
carbs protein and getting my fats yeah
okay that's the big one why is that the
big one uh I don't ingest a lot of fats
okay you know normally so I think having
a little and that's important for muscle
growth yeah yeah that's my understanding
I'm not an expert but anyway so as I was
putting this plan together I [ __ ] I
messaged Derek I go yo dude uh cause I
was talking to Sam Actually and Sam's
like just eat ice cream and I'm like
that that can't be dude Sam his view on
Fitness and Nutrition and everything is
so funny every like literally same thing
every time everything I bring to him
he's like that's wrong he's like this is
what works and whatever and like granted
like when he sticks to it he he does
like it works for him yeah and I
understand what he's saying but like
everything I say he's like no that's
that's what I've been telling you for
years
I know but I'm just starting to
understand it now okay copy some [ __ ]
slack yes and we get it you're thick
whatever so I hit up Derek replace four
days cycle yo bro have you heard of this
like you know just slamming ice cream
thing and he proceeds to send me a
personalized YouTube video
yeah yeah there's six voice notes and he
I'm just gonna play the beginning of the
first one yeah
I would no again
trying to ever follow a structured diet
where it's like more or less the same
thing every day but I'm I'm you saying
don't do that or do do that no no he was
saying like he was starting to discuss
like sort of like he's you know
qualifying like how have you ever you
know I don't know if you've ever
followed a plan like with macros and
stuff but as I'm listening to his voice
notes I literally then just feel like
I'm watching a seven minute video
targeted at me yeah and I just I I
messaged him like I feel like I owe you
AdSense for this because he just goes
through all these things where he's like
eat this for macronutrients and you know
there's more efficient ways to do this
and that I'm like God damn bro in six
minutes this guy just gave me like the
craziest amount of motivation so yeah
shout out shout out Derek so go to go to
his YouTube channel you know he came to
see us live no way yes in the video
where he reacted to us joking about
steroids yeah he mentioned he's like I
actually saw them live and they're
they're pretty funny dudes so if they're
ever in your town like go see him no way
yeah so that's just crazy to think that
he was just in the crowd that first one
with the with the carton yeah
awesome if you are wondering how to get
more protein then this is a really good
Method All right you can't get enough
protein what can I do I can only eat so
much meat in the day I can only have so
many protein shakes in a day you can
only have so much eggs you know fish
steak chicken stuff like that obviously
when I was younger I used to have a very
difficult time even hitting 1.5 times
not only is he huge but I feel like
what's interesting here is he's
definitely I feel like there's a level
of anxiety in him recording himself oh
definitely like he's fidgeting oh yeah
and it's just really funny to see him
this way not like now yeah where he's
just very like he can just talk to
camera very comfortably for a [ __ ] he
can but his video like the aesthetic
hasn't really changed oh no not at all
and I think it still films from yeah I
like how like people really [ __ ] with
him and he gets a lot of views because
he's so knowledgeable and yeah
straightforward with info but I love
that his V like the production quality
still sucks ass like he's at the
beginning of the video it'll still just
cut to like that disclaimer and it's
just silent like five seconds yeah
whatever yeah it's awesome
same thing like it just doesn't give a
[ __ ] it gets to the point obviously
there are differing opinions regarding
whether you actually need that much to
grow or not personally I like to hit 1.5
at least 1.5 times your body less and
they think it's sufficient and it may be
but I just find I grow best with 1.5 to
2 but besides that you know like debate
that's like a whole separate video but
as far as getting in extra protein
easily and the easiest thing that has
been enabled me to add an extra 100
grams of protein per day or what do you
think it is [ __ ] jug of milk no it's
a jug but it's a jug of something else
so basically this is
Derek
Derek are you sitting here saying we
gotta drink this whole carton of egg
whites [ __ ] no and dude there's like 200
grams of protein or something insane in
that I mean yeah I mean the cow the
calories on egg whites is so minimal if
you yeah I mean it's pretty genius and
it's also like there's a little sugar in
there I guess or something oh he was
like yeah eventually I got used to it
like he slams one of those every single
day and he's like walking around to
class and [ __ ] or he's like talking
about I don't know I was picturing
someone like in college just in in the
middle of like psychology class opening
up this carton of egg whites are
starting to slam
but he was like yeah I'm so used to it
it just tastes like sugar water to me
now and it's like an extra 100 grams of
protein like throughout my day that is
just I mean that motherfucker's
shoulders are gigantic so maybe I got
something to learn from this boy you
know training's still good because you
know if I if we ever decide to have a
kid you know I gotta carry that
[ __ ] I want my kid to feel like
I could beat his ass at any time and
that's just you know not that I'm gonna
do it but yes and no yes I know that I
could yeah yeah you can't have your kids
feeling like they could test you yeah
right when he's like if he's like 16 17
18 he gets some like recessive gene
because you know I got tall people yeah
yeah he's like my bloodline he's like
starting to wait five foot eleven when
did you yeah no no you should stop it's
very likely that my kid will be taller
than me what and if it's a dude sure if
he gets like 15 16 17 and he's taller
than me but still I gotta start building
the dad strength now so should he act up
I still hit him with a liver shot and he
was like oh that's my dad I said I told
you take that [ __ ] trash out yeah
that's why I'm that's why I run
so you can run away you wanna play catch